that's the worst I'm also negative we
should do to make the wish let's wear
these are from Georgetown cupcakes this
one looks like
[Music]
good tasty career huh
you better have a little bit rare oh
yeah oh yeah most people overcook it
is it nice right
let me see you deep till that bone I
mean either that cupcake [ __ ] my world
up that happens every time you know Wow
before this yes specially gifts that was
a lot a chunk of sugar I had licorice
this morning just eat the licorice in
the morning sky I woke up rode my bike
came back need a little sugar
the only way to get rid of your
stomachache whiskey 23 year old whiskey
shouldn't you gotta have so much your
birthday yeah ok let's get let's get
some cups going we got them
dad did you get the cocaine just get a
little just for a little bit both
snicker what for me a snifter little
snifter not a lot this is Brian's most
sniffed up it's nice
is this yours are my beautiful ok a such
beautiful whisk isn't it nice
this is you but you get 12 year old hey
sure why not it's his birthday
oh it's cat there we go
you're not Steve holiday no carefree wow
it's cool man me and Jason is gonna be a
very weird show you and who
that's so stupid oh man chickadee China
the Chinese chicken are you wearing that
shirt because you're Panther
oh no I kid though miss got this got so
sad what yeah we're gonna know what yeah
we're on we're on boom hey listen listen
you end it what you wouldn't did it yeah
you went and did the older can right now
I haven't seen the wings I can just see
its nose I can see it's [ __ ] nose I
did you say you didn't get the gap I /
like I told you you had to go and get
the [ __ ] pound terrified of snakes
I'm allergic to cat so pick your poison
and he decided just to get out it's
cancer
well this this represents I beat Corona
been tested twice now it does look super
so big those wings are too small to even
get that [ __ ] Panther off the ground
so now it's kind of annoying shitty
wings coming out like Jose you've seen a
flying Panther no I haven't then how the
[ __ ] would you know because this is how
I vision my aerodynamically it doesn't
make any sense there's no way as a mini
Panther well mini head stop doing that
no and by the way I got news for you it
looks more like a [ __ ] mountain lion
no way well this this artwork is so dope
Panthers you're so old it doesn't matter
but that has wings coming out of it it's
like kill hell and why did you choose to
have a panther with wings you know why
I'm just a I ride a mountain bike in
that I picture myself on that bike as
the president of the fake boys bike club
I'm going down the mountain I picture
myself as a panther with wings a panther
and I [ __ ] go hard dude uh-huh do you
want in the club I don't you can't I'm
skinny oh hold on
it's not likely I want to be your keep
me out of the club because I'm not
[ __ ] thick enough start eating dude
no because you know what my body type
doesn't call for thickness I'm thin man
I'll start my own company called thin
man thick board thin boy yeah it just
doesn't just a sign
same guy role didn't Boy hey who wants
to be part of the thin boy Club let me
say I will Rumble will Rumble with you
thick boys oh good luck with that dude
yeah you guys applied beat us but we're
quick and we're fast and we get
underneath chin I'm gonna send you a
picture from my boy
chin happy birthday thank you Brian 42
43 literally 43 today 10 years 43 men
wish you I wish you the 10 years I've
had no wow
somehow you obviously most of it for
sure the majority of it 10 years I've
had a good life
we've known you for what seven eight
years now no about four years almost of
four years a little old for years right
I think it's close to four years
carry me spoken I think you know I sent
you a picture chin from my guy Daniel
Silva when I say when I put out that
thick boy email or I'm sorry Instagram
post saying hey I need a tattoo artists
anybody down and so many sheep are like
no one's getting these Crona times good
luck loser when I say I had every tattoo
artist reach out yeah name one they all
reached out yeah this dude Daniel Silva
was like yo I'm in the Hills because you
can get gives him a tattoo and be covert
say what's one on one he's even tested
I've been telling you wear a mask then
we don't wear masks is around giant
[ __ ] but no I do yeah but he's been
tested I've been tested he's almost too
vain you do it there's nobody else there
that's his crib in the Hollywood Hills
by the way oh he's not he's not doing
well for himself
he's doing well oh he's not 25 when the
top tattoo artists in the world he five
guy he hook or to the kids on looker
he orders an Instagram page he's a Wayne
dimy dime yeah he's super good-looking
fella and an artist and they're not one
of the best artists tattoos all these
celebrities did he say alright I'll do a
panther if you're on he's like dude this
is sick and he's young eels let's run it
I was like [ __ ] let's run yeah he
went let's run this so [ __ ] I want to
say let me tell it
[ __ ] you let's run it dude let's run it
then I text him back I text him f Tech
don't dude thanks for running it when
he's five years old 25 one the top
tattoo artists in the nation in the
world was in San Francisco's like you
know what he was killing up there's like
any more of a challenge came to LA
bought a house in the hills in the
McLaren there you go he's doing very
well
kids killing it yeah he's an artist
Daniel Silva Silva what what ethnicity I
would say he's got to be Brazil
is Papa's Brazilian there's where he
gets the looks he said is it could you
maybe recommend that Brazilians on
average of the best-looking people in
the world know the guys look like [ __ ]
I don't think so the guys look like [ __ ]
guys are good really name one just up to
here Gracie who was younger Kron Gracie
who's young I mean these are
good-looking people um a lot of guys
that are good-looking a lot of a lot of
good-looking that they're pretty
good-looking yeah Luke Rockhold I mean a
lot of no but um there are a lot of
airlines off America in general yeah
Columbia Columbia my mate Brazil I'd say
the women are the best-looking the guys
I don't know I feel like the guys are in
Dagestan would have something to say
what do you mean most of their hideous
hideous they just yeah i but you see
this anxiety man yeah yeah they're don't
know a man you're like they made a gas
named Ian model right right they're just
not smart urges yeah but just they kind
of thick well they were toughest and
want better the toughest in the world
yeah you don't be good to be the
toughest in the world and the best right
now they look a little medieval yeah
I've got like the new room
so Harry yeah and it just wouldn't thick
thick you've seen a skinny no whoa who's
that guy I'm [ __ ] Tammy commit come
eat the beat the beat the beat seconds
that beep like this is he another artist
register guys okay Porter
that's Nyjah Huston who we've had on the
pile kid before our own the best that I
know when we interview them he's tiny
that's crazy how tall is this Silva kid
uh six one maybe okay star god damn he's
he's sexy right he is fine as [ __ ] I
know I know
Wow tall to go get the pictures when
he's like in Europe and [ __ ] he's just
mellow game well I'll leave this you
model bro he's obviously he looks like a
model to me that is a beautiful man
proud of him and he knows how to put it
together he knows he knows he's cuz he's
an artist so he knows yes he's got an
eye for proportion and color and
everything I mean you're not gonna well
just the I knew I wasn't good here and
he's rich yes and I just knew I was in
good hands with the details because I
brought something that like I drew it as
my
and he's like dude he can't to the flow
and he's like going over details like
and you can't put it there you have to
put it here Wow by the way so let me ask
you this go back to the go back to the a
couple up there so that that tiger is
that what he's drawing freehand was he
doing that for him really
he draws it on his computer print it out
puts the ink on your skin and then goes
huh it's like a like the outline on your
skin anything goes and his signature is
the colored eyes now I get chin for his
birthday seeing a tattoo on his neck
right how do you get that color on the
skin you'll be pretty white to get that
like my skin would it take to that Wow
yeah I guess I can get a tattoo now and
get those those blue eyes I've always
wanted yeah be cool oh my god she had
Tiger blue eyes whatever um but chin for
his birthday 43rd he's always wanting to
neck that to see her boy hooked him up
he's going tonight at six o'clock well
whenever I'm done with this
you getting your neck tat you bought him
a neck tattoo thank you very much what
are you gonna get on your neck it's
either gonna be a fish or a moon okay
now hold on hold on right no no I know
you're older so I know this isn't cool
to you I just think that in general I
okay I'm gonna be nice be nice because
remember he's a fisherman I do love this
kind of fish you know what's in it
Chin's heart grouper fish it's too fat
okay so you want attentions bones trout
trout but it doesn't look that great on
tattoo no no it looks like a fish
doesn't it that's the point you know
what my idea was for him what character
no that'd be cool I like where your
head's at yeah Siamese fighting fish now
that I understand why cuz it's specific
huh it's a fighter a badass-looking
they're very aggressive and they're a
little fins haven't gone yeah okay but
see now that's a beautiful tattoo
now that let's do detailed looking look
at the blue one though there's a bunch
this one look at that blue one that's
too much on chintz neck dude probably
neat simple on it and not color but I
like Siamese that's it so that I like I
I don't feel like there's any other
option but a Siamese fighting
ready I must run another one by you okay
you know who the the most underrated
fishes of all time hold on now if you
had a fish tank as a kid you'd know this
hold on hold on hold on I might know I
referred him as the janitor because he
cleans things up and the tank and he
looks very friendly okay
he might be a Blowfish or he might be a
selfish I said sucker fish sucker fish
might be a sucker fish none of these bad
boys
sacré fish but yeah that's how a bicycle
bicycle got sick I like the one with the
little top hat bad to me I like go with
humor so I like humor I like the one
with the top hat on that's really cute
although on your neck I might be a
problem the jet the Siamese fight you
could not get a tattoo on your neck
because you're 43 but you must and
commit to that then go with a Siamese
fighting fish what color are you gonna
choose black have to be black
really I'm rethinking the tattoo now
because I thought I was gonna be with
that crazy awesome hardest but another
guy that other guys other guys I heard
he's good - he's really legit yeah
you're not gonna be with the dimepiece
that's what I was thinking but no he's
not the guy in Santa Monica the dime
piece just so yet dime piece 2000 hours
booked out for two years only was that
Yelling's cuz he had a cancellation Wow
Jesus yeah chin I'm gonna see vans work
before how you being down your what did
you not look at the guy say you yeah I
saw this on some Instagram posts so
you're not feelin it chin also your
tattoo
Brian could do it a lot of people could
you're Brian could do it you don't need
[ __ ] Miami to do let's not get a moon
no no it's a little depressing to be
sick it's like a crescent but then it's
it's like with fish details that's what
I'm thinking right now safe no I didn't
even give me so small though it's me to
know that I actually did my girlfriend
did a thing here it's gonna be like
probably like that baby oh oh oh oh we
going okay if I'm gonna get on my now
okay Birdman
because that ready yeah yeah a third man
just money
thanks Sally
this is our first bonus episode [ __ ]
yeah nothing so far so good we're
crushing it can't wait til [ __ ] Will
Sasso face times in mm-hmm
now let me ask you this chin huh what is
it gonna be Siamese fighting fish no
Siamese Japanese let's do to do joking
oh really
yeah he can't yellows neck detail so
then so then maybe moon yeah I'm gonna
see this guy can actually do what I let
me see that would you say chin let me
see if you can do what I imagine cuz I
do imagine some some different details I
think like what so I'll be like a moon
but then there's gonna be a lot of
little you know like fish skills on it
not even skill it's just like kind of
cool little shapes and stuff and then
little little parts of like fish look
the eyes maybe a couple things here and
there sure sure
ya know it's gonna be tough I know it
why don't you just have to be so big for
that detail it'll be bigger
come on that size you spoken yeah that's
dope is that Tinkerbell it looks like
Sailor Moon how about that size though
not too much I thought I was thinking
smaller but your tattoo brother here
it's on your neck so I also don't
believe in running your tattoo by your
friends or family really no that's a
suede the suede suede me big deal yeah
then you overthink everything and then
you know yeah but also the tattoo is on
your body so it should be what you want
not what anyone else wants my body my
business yeah yeah necklace that girl
has on her chest that that sort of those
dots that's really subtle and cool right
and it was a really cool dude okay right
now if girl has a chest tattoo she do an
anal yeah that's fine it's yeah yeah
there you go so if a girl has tattoos
all over her neck up to her chin should
deep you're like I'd like to have sex
with her once once you know I mean
because sometimes you like ooh there
might be something I see a guy like that
I sure he's a nice person but I also I
have an inherent prejudice where I go
who he may not be too stable Yeah right
yeah usually big it's a big
big commitment but I see a girl I'm
thinking I get horny hang on yeah hang
on yeah when I see big felt dice in a
girl's shitty sports car I go I'm bushed
she's a bad girl yep and she's got like
fur around the license plate uh I'm in
you understand and and and lipliner
oh and heavy eye shadow and all that I'm
like all right I'm out of Tola I'm just
looking at a [ __ ] no I'm looking at a
professional look a nice cumdumpster too
much I'm sorry been drinking
you've been drinking please don't ever
say cumdumpster Tom Sam I have
apologized about too much about a lady
of the evening who's truly correct
you're right and she's in a Mazda mx-5
evan is 100% but gods turquoise it's 100
cats yeah you got me yeah cumdumpster
was too much well there you go
it's Friday thanks Jen I'm just trying
to type in milf just see like a regular
a regular milk go back go back to those
milfs let me see sash mum with Brian on
this now now define milf for me because
sometimes I'll see him and I'll go
that's not a MILF I just a hot chick
with huge tits um that looks what what's
really does lling that cog oh oh no no
that'd be a [ __ ] Jesus Christ what a
tiny person let's get that out of there
all right there's enough but also the
third one in that might be our friend's
girl bought last last page last row
third one in yep that my yep that my
dear friends girl Oh nope nope all right
yeah might be no it's not okay uh so
where were we
Oh chin your tattoo get it dude so moon
fish is there any other is there a third
it's just run through the ideas is there
any writing you could do if there is
there is there about musical notes Oh
what about a guitar music something
about music why wouldn't you do
something that is what you are like
music dude I've seen too many of those
tattoos that looks to me I'm sure they
look what about what about what
is what is your favorite what is your
favorite chord a flat yeah oh is that
the right word chord I mean is that yeah
but don't get that on you what's your
favorite verse your musical verse that
kind of moves you what's it what's the
most unique like you know it's like when
I hear Zeppelin like cannon and unique
yeah it does the tattoo well that was a
musician what would you do bro what
would be what would be the unique
inspiration a moon with fish scales on
it he's first hard drive for it I don't
want like a music no different that's
just pretty different
that's pretty gentle so random also Led
Zeppelin notes on your neck that's not
very original not not rillette Zeppelin
notes but whatever whatever music moves
you inspire hey cover your whole [ __ ]
night was cheating you know what we're
talking about these hit the showers no
because I believe if you're gonna write
something it's got to be specific and
meaningful no it doesn't touch it it
shouldn't be a problem right it'll put
this problem with older and a panther
with wing they put too much value it
like it's too much of a big deal tell me
on your neck forever it's on your neck
yeah he can hide that with his sleeves
which he's already doing cuz he he's
self-conscious I was tattoos well just
want you to stand up and be quiet you
have a hoodie on you're 57 so what it's
comfortable
hey chin you want the best piece of
advice I can give you your don't listen
abroad especially when it comes to
tattoos and business all right well well
hey you should have gotten a tattoo by
now Brian you know I mean least Jim
Carrey says what he's gonna do you know
I understand I just if you guys can give
me a tattoo that's good I'll get it get
a fish in the shape of a moon like
where's head that oh so maybe you can
shape of a moon that's you there a fish
in the shape of a moon that's what I'm
doing oh that's not thinking of that
might be alright let me see it I like a
moon covered in fish scales
also known as Cappuccio uh you know
these when fish turn it kind of looks
like a moon like a c-shape I mean I
guess too much oh that's a cute little
thing over there
I don't think Chin's going for cute
smile shot in your neck what did your
girl think of it chin was she in now she
didn't like it she liked it no god damn
it
well I mean cat do well uh yep
well think deeply about this don't
overthink it though no I do want I do
want to I've been wanting one for a long
time did he try to get one in when we're
in Dublin I want to do this on my neck
in Dublin bro just get a [ __ ] get a
ti-83 calculator now get the
testosterone molecule on your neck why
don't you get a [ __ ] and some guys have
that problem I'm spit ball some guys
actually have that problem what's that
big yeah all shaped up I don't know
where that is
that's just the way they're blowing I
look at the testosterone molecule that's
nice that's real nice
Oh chin gets self-made on your neck
self-made man no regressive testosterone
a lot of wild that too you go man there
are [ __ ] kids these days oh they're even
you know I might be a little outlandish
tattoos kids get the face and that
tattoos like that's their first ones now
it's just a thing where society you know
it's just a thing you're gonna get CEOs
with face tattoos part of part of being
older is that you see as people get
older and they were radical and crazy
when they were younger boy it becomes a
difficult thing to kind of manage now
yeah yeah I'm gonna try I'm gonna try
your ribs chin go for it
can I get a piece of that meat on your
[ __ ] get a pair of tongs like Korean
barbecue tongs
Tong's um alright so I think we'll might
be calling right now
let me check well that's nice June Nick
but now it's all cold good flavor
well con I wanted job Korean BBQ with
you before tip was City we're in Seattle
Seattle [ __ ] he is
yeah can't see you guys though
alright we're gonna turn yeah we're
gonna turn you give it a second you [ __ ]
is that better well you seem a little
bit it's great we're drinking whiskey
we'll it's Jens birthday oh thank you
all right let me get this
and we'll Brian's trying to copy your
haircut yeah he's gonna have its new
goodbye and I can see the crowd here
that's nice well have what I have 17
hairs on the top of my head and my old
man used to have something we called
Tony island you know okay well I have
more than that so I have more than that
Chanel okay well don't be shitty will
how's it to Don's what are you going
pretty uh pretty mellow so far yeah what
do you do with your days well not you
guys well any a tips for people in
quarantine yeah are you recording now
yeah we're recording now yeah yeah we
are don't tell me when we are Oh
you're live bro what are you drinking
your stupid mug what's that mother and
there's some coffee in here
don't you have some sort of intro or
something then we have to sit through 18
minutes no dude we done we all hate that
will its Will Sasso done hi I'm your
sass oh yeah welcome you to the program
I am welcome to the program
I watch you Ryan
yeah I mean it's great to be on the
fighter and the kid as you know more
importantly as the audience knows
there's a deep connection between me and
your audience this has been going on for
years ever since I won the first guest
of the year right through all right fine
you did win and now since it's been
rigged and I've been left off of that
thing every [ __ ] year or whatever
I've decided even though I don't give a
[ __ ] because I have this well I give a
[ __ ] about your audience and because I
have this relationship in the audience I
think it's time that I made myself
the People's Champ well this is a fanny
pack
WWE World Championship my buddy Chris
Fowler from back home gave me that
machine it's pretty cool well brain
jealous but you can't just name yourself
the People's Champ I mean that's kind of
like you know it seems a little
obnoxious and you're acting puzzled now
I can see on your stupid face yeah but
but this is something again I know it's
the fighter in the podcast yeah it is
between me and the people okay well but
you haven't think why we call it that's
why we call me the people [ __ ] okay job
sling that thing over your shoulder like
that
well well is that the same thing the
rock did is am I right on that yeah it
might be a little gimmick infringement
from the rock he did call himself the
People's Champ just wanna go like that
just want to make sure this is for
everyone making memes at home ready
that's good yeah that's good that's good
oh this thing go ahead another thing I
want to talk about is I want to
congratulate you guys on your format
change well what does that mean what do
you mean what do you mean well we didn't
even log in I'm congratulating you so
obviously you know about the format
change well here goes some more liquid
in your [ __ ] face and so then you'll
stop drinking yeah now you keep drinking
now what do you mean must
math change will well it's real simple
Brian this whole lockdown thing to self
quarantine thing of course a voluntary
thing and as far as you know the
government goes and look you don't know
a whole lot about my politics but I will
tell you I'm about this close from going
the wild country and doing whatever the
[ __ ] I please
Canada is a great place for that Wyoming
may as well be Canada and I'll [ __ ]
kill all the elk I need to eat don't
need guns maybe the most Canadian elk
murderer ever how do you kill the elk
without a gun dude it's it involves a
rear naked choke because they like to
charge more on that later here's the
thing let's not jump into who's politics
and who you're gonna listen to because I
know you guys probably well I don't you
know you guys clearly you're just there
no masks there the fighter in the kid
yeah I think there's so sort of that
reverse 5g thing you think mites killed
coronavirus yeah there you go
that's right there you go on well as you
know even shows like The Tonight Show
and dr. late-night this is Matt whatever
they're all dude they're all shooting it
from home and their interview
interviewing their spouses and children
I'm talking about traditional media well
is that where you're going with this
traditional media the tux correct okay
but fighting the kid not traditional
media okay and I'd like to congratulate
you on your change before the change do
news media because you consider
yourselves and a cinch yeah
an essential and essential business you
just glitched thank God it admittedly ha
no for connection will get a better
connection is it wills Connecticut are
ours
gotta go huh it must be him yeah it's
you get a better connection yes going on
you got dial-up is that what you're
using it using that dial-up yeah I get
that it makes that fax sound can you see
me can you yeah we can see you now and
way better
now way better now okay so here's so I
want to congratulate thank you your
format change to knees since you guys
are an essential service and providing
the news because clearly no one would
just go into a [ __ ] studio somewhere
to record a podcast right not that's not
about Mme I don't know and just you know
to [ __ ] just shoot the [ __ ] twelves
right thanks well I appreciate it well
you know what's crazy too is we've
actually doubled down we have three
three three episodes a week now
that's right during this quarantine time
yeah oh good because we are we are
essential because we break it down and
tell them how's business be better never
booming booming boom okay
so while that's good so while real work
in this country who are suffering by
staying home you guys are capitalizing
on that by making money and let's move
on to that news so what do you guys
about the corona virus as if you know
what the [ __ ] no no hold on well watches
you got will come our way couple things
both he and I are way everybody in this
room is negative number one number two
all been tested number two what Corona
her for antibodies turns out we're on
they yeah but one of us brother test bro
what test we took blood test cool so I
don't live together then well no that's
weird
so basically that got together so it
means nothing
especially when Brian I gotta see a
[ __ ] video of him [ __ ] putz around
with but bas Rutten yeah in [ __ ]
Oakland that's a good point well [ __ ]
dudes well you know so after that here's
the thing well here's the thing though
if we get it we're fine you're fine I'm
guessing you don't have any well there's
one in the [ __ ] directly in the
screen but do you have any LDL in your
life
I just Brian is that zero brother listen
up sunshine how old are your parents I
don't they're in Denver my parents are
80
yeah so are mine well my dad just passed
away I'm not interested side will get
mom to the coronavirus no I understand
that now I think if anybody is close to
somebody who's at risk
they better be goddamn careful and
responsible which is which I am around
by learn about this is that it's going
to affect different people differently
obviously people with you know
autoimmune issues people who have
diabetes
liberals liberal fighting shape liberals
liberals like yourself I mean anyone who
was really hoping not Americans like
yourself people who wander singing
Russians will one percent get thrown
virus and died mom but in order to
achieve herd immunity we have to behave
like the hurt unless we're talking about
the news media which now in the kit is I
got some [ __ ] news not gonna give
them funny you don't text this is what
I'll open up next week yeah everything
except for schools this is its own
[ __ ] country Florida and I'm sorry
sorry Florida far away pretty far away I
[Applause]
got another one
how about Ohio's open up to what do you
say about Ohio yeah we will Big Willie
style like oh yeah yeah we have slowed
the curve because we've been staying
outside so look forward to cowboys oil
men and cows to get all sorts of [ __ ]
coronavirus in Texas and it won't matter
in Ohio because LeBron is already here
go on ok hold on hey will hahaha how
long you want to shut down the cow well
this dude is no here's more news this
too shall pass
yeah
may 15th I'm going to eat out to dinner
yeah hey will how about maybe 15th we've
dried over to your castle and beat the
[ __ ] out of you come on over I'll tell
you what if you want to come over to my
owns axes okay
you know what here's what I got entering
snap free well they projected two
million it's gonna be under sixty
thousand well they projected two million
like two months ago yeah that's what
that is fairly Sweden that didn't enact
much of a lockdown but then you know
what happened in those past few months
we quarantined know where I am
we're all practicing safe we're all
faxing save our no no we'll hey we'll
how long for how long yes even though
[Music]
I'm gonna be there before May 15th
yeah and I'll tell you something else
[ __ ] [ __ ] roll around and
you'll separate both my shoulders and my
knees and bloody my face and when I show
up to the hospital they're gonna say
sorry no room for you mr. Sasso cuz all
these [ __ ] beds full of rotavirus
patients because wrong wrong you're
wrong
there's so many beds wide open there's
beds wide open sir we ciders back we use
it we're so good we set them back we
said well yeah Trump and Trump is
sending them to Russia i I do some
epidemiology work and I can tell you
this virus looks very
and then most blurry go we have a handle
on yeah how's it different than let's
say birds or stars very easy it tends to
be a little prickly or a little bit more
round loom and a just and a little bit
words mean nothing yeah it's got a it's
just got a bit of a stickier kind of
attitude you know in intensive you know
kind of gets an air kick it guide causes
some issues and we're working on that
right now I have good friends that are
really starting to crack this code and
we are very [ __ ] close it's coming up
with treatment and very close to come up
with a virus in this country which you
are not from so that's an important
thing for our listeners realize is that
you are a bonafide
a bonafide we collectivist aka
communists from the north of [ __ ]
Canada
yeah and and we'll take your country
over if we want so that's the other
thing
yeah what you're more American than me I
agree with hello why number one you were
born on a ship in Singapore
[ __ ] you and then your dad dragged you
over in your diapers and then you went
to [ __ ] whatever sort of weird
boarding boarding schools fetched by
girls on the rest of this guy real kid
will the real kids decided to be an
American I decided I made the choice
right didn't just slip out of you know
what I [ __ ] decided I'm coming down
here
I'm taking my Canadian flag I'm taking
my World Championship and I'm coming
down there I'm Way more American than
you Brian as a matter of fact come May
15th let's do this apple-pie make you
more American than me
[ __ ] you challenging you right now as
soon as this [ __ ] lockdown is lifted
apple pie eating contest or you can do
it outside in the park 6 feet apart but
you have to wear a mask and eat apple
pie you son of a [ __ ] I'll [ __ ] show
you how because I'm more American than
you use the son of a [ __ ] this is a
[ __ ]
choked down a [ __ ] steak after that
that's right I'll have a Texas meat
dessert after my apple pie a Texas meat
dessert god Anna well you took us a task
here you got on this [ __ ] vodcast via
little Adele who you want that for and
you are gonna view us the riot act and
you're accusing us of being uncovered
safe because well you know what Brian
here let me let me actually watch your
words dude 23 year old whiskey which has
been proven proven Cheers lab to [ __ ]
kill covetous [ __ ] tracks how's that
water yeah why don't you stick a blow
dryer in your mouth doesn't that work
does work knows what so does going to
church and so does going to [ __ ]
church keep going
hey will if you're scared go to church I
wish you wasn't glitchy me too I wish
you weren't so based on those yeah
you're wearing a mask not yet
my face is cold it's not like I look
like katana we lost you will oh there
you are again long time yeah you hear
that okay
alright Brian you know what here's how
about how about this for uh for a
[ __ ] capitalist agenda
the more you ignore the lockdown and
tell your audience that there's no
[ __ ] problem by by way of you know
just kind of we're providing
entertainment during these tough times
yeah you son of a [ __ ] alright you're
providing entertainment because there's
not millions of hours of screaming
[ __ ] no bro we are quality Lulu
you're asking for it dude and we do
[ __ ] current events which is news
news you can't hear you [ __ ]
you know that's now you're back this is
perfect
alright alright here's here's my thing
the longer you ignore the lockdown right
yeah when I do the line
you tow yard are you there entertainment
entertainment essential news okay not
essential news okay wait that's right
you guys are news now yes the longer you
do that the longer you do that longer
we're gonna have to push back the
adventure return of the podcast
[Laughter]
ergo okay so now on because we dropped
some hints and you know Chris was like
hold on let's not tell everyone yet and
I was like okay and then someone hit me
up saying Brian just spilled the beans
on some [ __ ] military podcast and
they [ __ ] sent me a link I watched
about a second of it
how boring well I got I got [ __ ] I
got so [ __ ] bored I slipped into a
anyway I'm not gonna go there here's the
thing when those people blow me up on
social media I'm gonna let them know
that it's year for now hold on well
that's not fair that's not fair come May
15th we're we're at it we're at it with
the with the 10 minute podcast
now I'm gonna rough you up a little bit
will so you might miss a few episodes
bummer to rough you up for this you're
getting buff dude now I'm gonna be
jerking off in the corner do you know
Brandon are you familiar with you know
when it comes to the People's Champ and
wrestling in this whole thing are you
are you are you you're familiar with the
[ __ ] comeback someone getting their
fair at the end of the match yeah sure
man yeah doing that whole thing yeah and
pointing in the whole thing so you
better be careful cuz if you beat the
living snot out of me I'm gonna haul up
and then you're gonna have to solve for
me okay you're gonna have to you're
gonna jump a little bit when I slam you
and when I [ __ ] drop the elbow your
will will that's a good story that's a
that's a good story you new source hey
well did you did you see the WWE
trying WrestleMania with no crowd I know
I know you're big Russell fan I know
this how embarrassing is it with no
crowd it was it was it was the wrong
thing to do some would say the most
wrong thing to do
well yeah theme of today yes the wrong
thing to do and one of the longest
things to do I could I watch less of
that than I listen to Brian on that
military pump
it made it made no sense it made no
sense it was like watching your cousin's
play fight in the basement yeah it was
so awkward it's it's weird you watch
grown men do that it's very weird
awkward it's an indictment of the art
form
yeah because I'll call it an art form
but I'll also make this face because
when you're doing it without a bunch of
people it's like in a way that they've
already planned okay
that aside yeah we did you figures Texas
Ohio okay hang up on you we're going in
the [ __ ] we're going in the [ __ ]
current events Jack
yeah news we have dr. drew on here hey
we're dr. drew on here who broke it down
for us got me and next you have dr. Phil
who said to 360 thousand deaths occur a
year in pools across the country when
it's more land when it's actually 3,600
so he's an idiot
and dr. Drew is not but this let's play
a little game I'll do some current
events with you okay last week last week
from Naples to April 12th you guys know
how many I do know his deaths across the
board in the United States I know that
[Music]
for Disease Control and I encourage
[ __ ] out here
you have your mind dude and I'd say what
made 15 you were not gonna last dude you
know the good news is that this the peak
is likely already happened there's been
less hospitalizations as a few days ago
then there were a few days before but a
lot of hospitals get shut down
you know that they don't have enough
patients did you know that what's that
some hospital is actually shutting down
in California because they're not enough
patients then please don't share things
that Brian told you that he may have
heard from someone else but just before
you started rolling hey do you guys know
what the number one killer of people was
last week the week between between the
days April 6th April 12th it might have
been Corona price bright Brightcove in
nineteen no it was not it was heart
disease oh I got it right here heart
disease was responsible from April 6th
April 12th for twelve thousand six
hundred twenty six deaths I'm sorry dude
I'm starting to [ __ ] sweat because
you're pissing me off will and I'm gonna
take my coat on answer
11400 37 and on down the line accidents
was 2911 diabetes was 1586 the flu
pneumonia right the common influenza
sure 1010 or 27 suicide was 876 yeah
sure it was I was carjacked well I got
some news for you did you know what the
economy getting so shitty and everybody
losing their job suicide is gonna go
through the [ __ ] roof do you ever
think about that
[ __ ] well don't make this alright well
it's not me about you dude let's not
make you about you I'm talk about
society in general [ __ ] no he'll do
number two Colvin 19 was responsible for
twelve thousand three hundred ninety two
deaths that's five times the size of
Pearl Harbor which maybe your daddy told
you about Brian hey and if this
continued if this continued sure it's a
peak its April right let's hope it goes
away
no soda what has been saying yeah well
it's going away because people are on
lockdown
that's right the fighter in the kid
podcast or watching Seinfeld reruns or
any number of [ __ ] sharp [ __ ] up
I'm a supporter I'm a supporter of the
of social distancing smart
yup smart shot you not no you're not
yeah discontinued for a full year right
and keep in mind we don't have a vaccine
for another 17 yeah it should continue
for a full year that's hundreds of them
it's a dad's hey why are you laughing
why do you laugh you think it should
continue at that trend will that's in
well well you just broken okay take it
easy
all right five anyone can get a passport
yeah I got a guy I know a few guys
alright listen my back is hurting from
leaning forward like I'm sweaty you're
super gradually blood red mad to use
your word you make me blood red now
[ __ ] smack centrist I'm a [ __ ]
staunch libertarian you're coming off
[ __ ] and a politician or political
party I use [ __ ] this okay yeah yeah
yes I do
all right so I feel not just how I feel
sure sure hey will you Texas Ohio yeah
you burn my Chile will [ __ ] maybe we
will hey stop doing it alright your arms
are bigger big deal dude what the [ __ ]
stop flexing bro you look like the guy
from 90 day fiancé
stop doing that alright listen well we
want to thank you for popping in we
really we really no it's just a it's
hard to hear you because your neck hurts
dude I'm just reading you're also super
glitchy and you're a communist know your
audience this yeah guys please stay
tuned for the eventual return of the ten
minute podcast when Brian get does that
out of his ass and until then okay well
that's great we saw that no you have a
jam we got it now will we look forward
to getting you in studio and I'm gonna
see come
listen I'll tell you what while you
[ __ ] what what as soon as she gets
relaxed even a little bit because look
100% honestly I'm doing what I'm doing
as an example just because I feel like
it's the right thing to do and that's my
opinion and that works for me
I appreciate it you guys have you guys
have a business that's already rolling I
like that you guys have gone the
distance to to get tested you know and
that sort of thing yeah I know you guys
are hearing a lot of stuff from a lot of
different people because you've put
yourselves out there I don't have a
podcast currently [ __ ] won't for at
least the next month because of Brian
but I will say I will say this is from
everything I've heard yeah you read a
new some the other day you talked about
okay here the [ __ ] five things I need
to see rah rah rah
but once the [ __ ] numbers come down
and numbers of bright Brendon numbers
are not States okay so when you say here
are the numbers Ohio Texas yeah but but
California's going down will we're
actually we need 14 days of decline of
steady defense right which is happening
we know all this will any other
brain-busters is you know ok restaurants
been a little look a little differently
they're gonna space the tables out we're
gonna throw away the [ __ ] table
covers everyone's gonna be wearing
gloves and ask this in there
sure people with under the best shape of
my [ __ ] life ok so I'm not worried a
little respiratory disease I'll uh get
[ __ ] I'll put salt in your whiskey
gargle that and run up a hill ok but
that's just me so once they need to
relax a little bit I
do you think that everyone that we
should look at it in different stages
unfortunately we can't contact trace
when things online
South Korea we're in phase one one phase
one yep you know what whatever phase 1
of the program to come back to let the
economy come back phase one bro okay so
once we can actually come back and it's
more about and we've spread it out with
regard to you should be going to work
and who should sure I got no problem
sitting in a room with you know five or
six [ __ ] people yeah we're gonna beat
you up we're gonna be chopping you'll be
just a plate for this podcast okay
monitor with an agenda wait show me a
little bit show me a little Dicky didn't
did knew some set you up to this is that
what's going on here you [ __ ] so [ __ ]
here's the [ __ ] news Brendan if you
if you [ __ ] get if you you know
[ __ ] pull an octagon you know on here
whatever it is that what they say
yeah Mme if you ever heard of that term
sure I'm a decorated high school athlete
right median but if you decide yes what
hold on no he's the best course Oh horse
I told you dial up the nightmare this is
the one thing I hate about furious he's
bad I noticed your liberal rant finish
your thought what I'm saying was when
Brandon finishes reach it into my mouth
dislocating my job while he punches my
ribs purple and then I become the
governor I'm gonna make it harder for
you to get out of prison I know her
friends and you know who else was
friends Tim Robbins in that [ __ ]
warden with the glasses in the mean face
he thought they were friends I'm not I'm
gonna do that and in the end there won't
be any Morgan Freeman waiting for you
and Zihuatanejo [ __ ]
I will keep you in a cushy Sacramento
prison dude cuz I will [ __ ] run for
governor
especially after I win that [ __ ]
apple pie eating contest you heard it
here first folks the People's Champ
versus the kid it's the real kid versus
the kids apple pie eating fun no I
didn't say yes this is more American no
I ain't say any of this alright look
well we appreciate you joining us we
love you hide you smoker can you light
up a joint yeah let's take a photo
picture will hold on stay there we're
gonna take a picture it's still there
[Music]
Brian give them your dick doing current
events let's see what's happening in
current events in this current event
Brendan Shaw with huge arms getting
tattoos yeah get tattooed by Sergio
dimepiece thank you right now bike dude
thanks strong do you guys even want to
talk about this one it's I mean they're
all gonna be you know closely related to
covet 90 it's just what it is I'm asked
to think alcohol stops Corona
well because it's a disinfect any sense
would you drink whiskey to get rid of
the flu well this anybody's looking for
excuses to drink sure people are like
alcohol sales at 55% increase from this
time last year I'm drinking a lot at
night I only drink when I have nothing
to do and at night I'm like I'm like if
you put anything in front of me right
now I'll do it I really only drink him
only time I drink it when I'm working I
don't drink at home do you yes the World
Health Organization came out and said
that they wanted to remind everyone that
drinking alcohol will not help them well
you realize how tough you can't you
realize how stupid people are will like
just like this they think I'll call the
injury to get through the corona or when
the hurricane was in Florida and people
were dead to give out a warning saying
please don't fire automatic weapons into
the hole into the Hurricanes that
actually doesn't affect it that was an
actual
warning that you'll please bullets will
not face the hurricane it's awesome
please don't fire guns into the
hurricane excuse me
some people are [ __ ] so dumb mm-hmm
hurricane crazy yeah okay since March
Madness has been oh is this all I got a
pic free different do you see the ten
yesterday Brian what did I tell you no
I'm not saying it's right but a lot of
Pete up I'm telling you people aren't
gonna get locked down for too much
longer they they do most people get seen
under who are health you're going [ __ ]
this dude I'm about to freak out I'd
rather take my chance to get Corona did
I send you this chin what a picture of
the 10 the 10 freeway
no but it's a bumper traffic yeah no I
was in traffic today
oh no I'm talking bump dude bumper to
[ __ ] bumper bro no I wasn't bumper to
bumper traffic on the end of the earth
we're out here here it is this is the
tension yesterday your boy was on the 10
oh my feeling good take that it you look
at you look at Michigan they're
protesting they're just the people like
dude we have no money we're [ __ ]
hungry how many kids are gonna start
because they don't get the meals at home
I'm sorry they don't get the music real
school yeah how many kids gonna start
that's one of the current events there
are a lot of protests popping up
throughout the country where people are
poor basically yeah they're basically
saying that they need to get back to
work you got to remember that
unemployment was at 3.2 percent before
this do you know that that's more than
full employment that's more than full
employment I think you know people are
unemployed right now
yes ascension yesterday Wow Wow
bumper-to-bumper people aren't having it
was that who sent you that it's it's
someone posted this holy Sh
so this is the ten yesterday people are
getting very anxious you know and don't
want to be cooped up anymore damn
they're looking at the statistics go
hard I hope I'm healthy I'm under 50 I
don't hang around old people why the
[ __ ] am I still staying inside well I
think well I I've tried to be really
neutral about this to an extent and in
terms of I don't
know enough about this virus right we
know no it's yeah we do know there's a
full-scale investigation to see if this
actually was a military virus can they
came in lab we so I don't know um but I
will say this I think historians are
gonna look at this in the near future
and really we're gonna get a very clear
picture on whether or not this was an oh
a major overreaction
I believe Sweden yeah get lost down
numbers are very similar doors they are
so III believe that they there has to be
and this is no this is no sort of dig on
anybody but there's got to be a smarter
way to do this that's not very Cove it's
safe sorry you understand so so so I
think we're gonna find I think we're
gonna find a more creative way to deal
with a pandemic got caught with our
pants down I'm freaked out
yeah and but we have to come up with a
more creative way we just do and we will
mm-hmm and we will what's this get
create our way out of this problem
create a low because March Madness was
cancelled there's a surplus of chicken
wings here in the States
cuz nobody is going out of their way to
buy chicken wings I don't feel like
chicken wings during this time out most
people aren't going out having barbecues
grilling or anything you know what their
thing about doing with sports well
especially an NC double-a football and
this is the number one reason why
college athletes should be paid
especially in football you know what
they're gonna because they don't things
to be safe to have people in the arenas
but that's how they you know that's how
almost all colleges make their money is
off the football program so they're
saying we'll financially these
institutions these university is gonna
shut down less than a football season so
they're delet they what they are one
thing one plan that's in play that the
thing about doing they're gonna push the
football season to the spring because
the the universities need money and then
what do you think is do in the fall the
same season so those kids would play 12
games or 18 games I may fight BCS cost
Oh three months that's hilarious
a month off I might even play another
season why are they doing that for
financial reasons that's the only reason
they will do it for financial reasons to
save the universities and you don't want
to pay these kids yeah and you're gonna
force them because of financial reasons
to risk all this yeah just say
the institution's that's insane this
insane it's not fair what the athletes
should do is go weren't unless she gets
a piece of the pie we're not [ __ ]
playing in the spring or the fall and
then your favorite players like Lawrence
the starting quarterback for Clemson
who's supposed to be the no 1 pick well
he's not gonna play cuz he's gonna get
in the fall so why would he play why
would he play this weird season in the
spring sure and he's definitely not
playing in the fall of risk injury he's
gonna skip all of it because he didn't
get ready for the season the fall of NFL
Wow Wow think about [ __ ] yeah well this
virus it's gonna change a great deal
about how we do a lot of stuff it's
gonna be very interesting to see it
really is and I would imagine that
because people have been forced to use
things like zoom and stuff for
conferences and meetings with like
Microsoft you're probably gonna see more
that too you know you're about zoom
stock no no that uh they're not prepared
for the data collection that they're
doing oh wow so yeah people shouldn't I
don't know
yeah a lot of people have been getting
hacked on zoom there have been people
like basically going into classroom
sessions and disturbing it somewhat some
of it has been like it just jokes kind
of on dick pics yeah dick pigs asking
like stupid questions will be like who's
that and there are other instances where
people are going in saying races [ __ ]
not hilarious not funny it's what people
do idiots mm-hmm
I know well I was with my buddy in high
school boarding school and they were
doing a play and [ __ ] we get behind a
curtain they're doing a play they're in
the middle of play me and my idiot
friend get behind the curtain and my
buddy well he and my buddy just goes I
want to suck your tits screams and the
top of his lungs in the middle of the
play
right behind the car yeah we ran almost
sunny this June this made me laugh so
hard I don't know why it's cuz
quarantine times things are so [ __ ]
stupid
but this lady's ordering and her son
wrote down what he wants and her son
added
her son added sloppy Weiner so she's
going cheeseburgers reading for it she
goes fries cheese burger chicken
sandwich and a sloppy wiener and that's
like scuse me I don't know why I thought
it was so [ __ ] fun him I love stupid
[ __ ] I'm a cent T now Jen this is so
[ __ ] funny I don't have stupid [ __ ]
like that I mean it made me laugh so I
don't it so I can tell a story just deaf
Tony Jefferies has talked about this but
when he was on the Olympic team the Nash
team in London the Olympics were in
London Tony was on the team and Billy
Joe Saunders was on the team and they
would all get together the other
athletes in the Olympics and they would
ask him to sign all this all this stuff
balls boxing gloves giant pictures well
somebody somebody kept drawn a huge [ __ ]
on everything and it was such a problem
that the Commissioner got all the
athletes giggles hey listen we auctioned
the stuff off to pay for a lot of
important stuff whoever's drawing dicks
on things you will be found and you will
be kicked out of Nash team if you keep
bidding we don't want to see it again
now there's a thing back there there's a
poster one everybody sign we better not
see a dick on it well this dude Billy
Joe Saunders drew a huge party one of my
favorite a Jewish Hassan it he's my
favorite drew a huge dick on the poster
yeah I love that guy Tony said they
could not stop laughing every time he
did it ruined all the stuff he is
turning oh shoot this Lucy fight next
were they talking about Hammond Canelo
he [ __ ] up though what made a video
goes I know a lot of people with their
significant other right now you're
getting on each other's nerves and he's
on a heavy bag he goes so this is how
you stop him he goes so when you're
girls arguing she's give me [ __ ] well it
was bad
he goes you hit her with a left hook and
she's gonna be a little wobbly and then
you finish her off to the body
I've been psyching that [ __ ] won't say
anything oh dude came over his is his
boxing license got revoked [ __ ] they're
not fighting can I mean [ __ ] [ __ ] can
they stupid and he's like I was only
joking all right you're suspended yo
just win it [ __ ] dude come on don't do
this would you not gonna fight a
megastar like Kanab an older friend like
me who can be like no
that's not funny though it's not funny
dude slay this Jenny of the mall you
meup yeah she's worn that Sonic I think
his teenage son made the drive to order
for his mom your than a cheeseburger
Jinja in a sloppy leader and a sloppy
wieners puppy dog it's so stupid and a
sloppy wiener dude I was I was so funny
out like laughing out loud this morning
at this protest against stay-at-home
orders pop up across the country
what'd I tell you B yeah you did you
vote yeah can your feeling you have good
your finger it's always on the pulse yep
people throughout this country are tired
of being unemployed so a lot of people
are going out of their way to protest
now I'm telling now wait for these other
states and start open up I know will
make fun of me but they are opening up
Ohio there's a plan for them to open up
not yet but there's a plan for them to
open up Ohio Texas all these their plan
open up right so when people see them
open up and our numbers are better than
them and our [ __ ] liberal [ __ ]
governor wants to lock this down I'm
telling you people aren't gonna put up
with it and that's why you see the 10
bumper-to-bumper traffic that's why when
you go to the part it's packed like
right like you said people are first of
all this is very difficult for a lot of
people this is very scary for most
difficult and scary you know when you
say for example well you're 409 K is not
as important as human lives that's not a
thing to say to people because we're not
people or not you can't say if
somebody's really terrified at their
retirement that they've worked their
whole life that they don't also care
about human lives that's not what's
going on here people are terrified and
desperate about their futures and about
this impending depression and I think
you're right when they actually look at
the hard numbers and they go I'm not
generally an at-risk person you know
what if I do have the antibodies what if
I am negative and I have friends have
had it I now know six people have had
and they're fine it sucked
it sucked I know people have had it they
even show symptom but it's sucked and
there are a lot of people are
asymptomatic and so I I do with this guy
obviously I'm Way over here right like
there's people in the middle people over
here won't leave their house we're mask
won't have sex and then I'm over here I
kind of grew this guy give us all the
information we need and let it let us
decide special were 50 under with not
line conditions this dude says the
government at all levels has overstepped
its authority in the request to protect
Americans from the virus while
well-intentioned it's naive for the
mayor and others to think shutting down
our local economy will protect families
the American citizens is perfectly
capable of deciding how to best protect
themselves we have rich we have a rich
history of solving problems without
government interference TRO give us
information and suggestions if you must
then step aside allow Americans to take
action and I think that's a very fair
and certainly a very American if they're
educate Americans yes yeah be educating
the situation we can't go around older
people or people without line conditions
but two to three hundred fifty
they have no underlying conditions and
you're healthy you go back to work and
you're gonna see all these other cut the
all these other states do it and our
[ __ ] liberal governor is gonna drag us
through longer and longer the guy he's
gonna go like this
suicides you go like this I think the
governor and people like this are also
terrified they were terrified because
they didn't have all the information
well they want to be over safe but they
would have 300,000 well you know I think
Newsom was looking at New York with a
lot of terror New York was losing you
know so many people and very old but
that's not that's not to say that those
lives don't matter believe again my
parents are 80 [ __ ] would hate to
lose that
but but so you know you understand a
governor erring on the side of caution
there's no doubt that this it's a [ __ ]
difficult time this is a very difficult
thing to navigate it really is man it's
just it's really difficult I found
myself saying I don't know a lot you
know dude I'm a dumbass I don't know but
but I think you're right i think i do
think that we get to a point where i
don't know but i wonder what is it
before the economy goes into a smarter
way to do this especially in the future
let's learn from this let's figure out a
way to be targeted with our lord of
everything learn from anything learn
from new york who you know was
overwhelmed with things in the
hospital's already learn from sweden
that didn't lock down and there the
rates of the same as us learned from
south korea that shut down early in
taiwan learn from [ __ ] china that was
complete disaster while china wasn't
released that's but i'm trying to didn't
really share their notion for at least
five minutes with us yeah and and and
that the chinese communist party not the
chinese people to change coming big
distinction so that's this gin thing to
get out of the whole corona thing this
is just something fun that
powell-peralta you know that skateboard
burn skateboard dude okay yeah anyways
just watch
[Music]
oh my gosh it's like that song so good
they're brothers yeah I would imagine
these kids are great beauties my
brother's over at dawn left it's over
that's pretty badass
dude you don't realize like my son's
only four and yesterday I was gonna get
my tattoo right I was going on at eleven
I was gonna be there for two hours and
here's Papa where you go cuz we're in
the pool name is Papa where you going on
you know I gotta go to work because if I
don't wanted to describe it sighs so I'm
going to work I come back and goes where
are you worried look what Papa guy would
show my tattoo he's left that he loves
tattoos I look at my tattoo yes but he
didn't go to work I open full heels you
said you're going to work I know he goes
getting a tattoo is not gonna work pop
wow I can't wait to see him - I was like
dude take it I get to see this so I
can't [ __ ] wait so - I can't wait get
a tattoo is not going to work
he goes you lied know what I guess yeah
but I meant I was like oh I was getting
work done with a tattoo yes that's not
going to work
I'm arguing with him right now all right
that's cool he cracked me up in that
video okay let me watch that video he's
like I was on the phone and it's a
calculator so fun what else you get one
last one just a fun one this is Tyson
Fury you know it's I said I'll blow the
belt he did this like exercising with my
wife yeah yeah so he did this with his
wife on Instagram wife and then his son
well I'll play for his son says some
crazy [ __ ]
[Music]
all of you Frank Kubrick
dude I'm laughs get started dude how
about so might be my son play a game
where I go
how about rip your have a rip your nose
off name is huh Byron we just keep
naming body parts and have I rip your
lips off you just have I rip your teeth
teeth off other than I'm gonna rip your
eyes off here's how I rip your [ __ ]
ears laughing oh you're what oh my son
here's me cuss on the phone that's
really good i tsundere I don't [ __ ]
care like whoa they say not to tell kids
like you can't say that that's a bad way
never use that word I said I go where'd
you get that he goes from you yes I
record oh when to use it you the
obviously they're gonna hear it no one
to use it and he's in school I recorded
it yesterday and then some stuff then
some stuff I [ __ ] up on his dad cuz uh
just take a piss we're in the hot tub I
pee and there's yellow news hits in the
hot tubs my hot tub is chlorine you just
piss and also please and hot tubs so I
people have to be as popular I can pee
in the hot tub you can pee the hot tub
my girls hold on
no he can't I go why not she goes she's
thinking with his friends it's not say
urine
yep it's my pool and there's tons of
chemicals kill it I don't care don't
piss in your door peed in the pool
no I don't ever know I don't piss and
pool oh oh I'm sorry
I'm never saying you just said I went to
the beach with them dug a hole yeah what
is the old peace out yeah pissed in the
same
[ __ ] I'm not gonna piss in the
goddamn [ __ ] you know it's my pool oh
my gosh
I but my girls brought up a good point
she goes no he can't I go okay even pee
in the pool there's chemicals it's fine
I got pee in the pool before she does
here's the prom Brenda I didn't think
she was he's in good his friend's house
gonna be at school and they go to a pool
thing and he's gonna piss in and all the
kids are like oh that's right in pools
sounds like I didn't think of that
yeah and you just piss in a pool hall
it's my pool and piss in your [ __ ]
hot tub welcome to just your poor hot
tub you would piss in anyone's yeah just
piss that annoys me about you really
yeah you piss in a [ __ ] you'd piss in
that in a deprivation out there you're
gonna have to edit this out I've seen
you anyways I've seen you wash ashore
I've seen I've heard you wash your ass
and sinks before I'm not gonna say if I
wash my ass and sinks let me explain
this to you know that my whistle is
always as clean as the plate you take
out on the fathers gay man I'd respect
that yeah I keep my whistle trimmed and
timing smooth tight tight and clean I
can't walk around with a dirty whistle
fast I can't do it no good for you yeah
yeah it's a very clean whistle and I got
a impressive dick and I'm sorry to say
that he'll just send me pictures on I'll
see it another skill yeah they lazy lazy
old heavy their day some days when I'm
just my date I'm tired my body's tired
my I pay he doesn't really doesn't play
with the dick picks is when you and I
sent him in the group chapter knew you
me and alia Tilly it really doesn't part
yeah sends me dick pics I've had plenty
of dick pic he really doesn't like he
doesn't play with it that terminus I've
had him send me his dick has dragged
dick too he's got he's got he beats both
of us
Lee he's got a piece of those rogen one
time I pretended I was catching a mouse
and then I I brought the camera over and
I was squeezing my my soft piece as hard
as I could so you could just see pieces
of a chemicals yeah and he was like he
was just like whatever I was like what
makes you feel so stupid that people
don't play with that yeah I know I was
like hey oh we feel this most stupid no
like oh you're not the guy I guess
descend and I understand maybe I should
grow up maybe because I was in my late
40s when I did it I understand but when
I said my girl dick baby I go man this
thinks something's wrong with it she was
wild it bit it's something bit it got
all swollen
she was waiting you're the doctor hold
on
my my Amanda when we were married she
was with a group of her friends at a
birthday we're all like shed this girl
group that would get together for brunch
and I sent her an impossible picture of
good lighting I mean just heavier full
mast full mast the thing was literally
stretching my did you do yes I get it
I just went thinking of you good didn't
it was before she would have it
Anisha hopped a little screen she's
trying to cover and apparently how those
girls know what's up babe they should
know what's I don't know what's you get
a lot of dick pics cat yeah funny ones
all sense my friends girls Tony sent us
to us okay your friends your girls
friends know everything about your piece
cuz she absolutely right everything yeah
everything shins girl I came in today I
came in early and I just she had a mask
on she oh hey good to see you like I was
like excuse me do I know you see us I'm
Chin's girl for I felt so stupid she
goes I'm Chin's girl matter before yeah
I don't know you guys both met her she
had a mask on she had a dress on that's
tough Jeff Cisco cops [ __ ] she's
gorgeous
she's beautiful yeah she's gone chin
thank you well does make you dinner
tonight for your bday my birthday sloppy
joe slappa slappa Joel yeah sloppy we
know yeah yeah what else you got that
was it that was last one there's a long
shot on his spot it was in a long show I
hope does that is awesome bonus I'm not
mad are you mad at the bonus Friday
I love the bonus Fridays I think we
should do a lot of bonus Friday me too
all quarantine are we gonna [ __ ] do
besides who
I was talking to Jay because we got over
eight weeks before that Spokane
Washington date end of June which you're
gonna come with me but it's looking good
it is it's looking very good [ __ ] a
man already opened up there ahead of the
curb so there they got hit the first so
I am so down
huh fun with that I'm so down bro spoke
anybody get your [ __ ] mouth ready
positive attitude and you know do you
understand that Washington wines I got a
place in Spokane they got some [ __ ]
beautiful wines
well now you need step your cardio up
did you know daddy started a big boys
bike club in every city I go on tour we
get together we ride bikes in the
mountains is that true that's true
think boy bike clubs real and we have
merchants Giarrusso videotape that for
me sent it to me I can go not a bike
rider bubble each cruise I'll be screws
not a big mountain biker I plus I'm not
a thick boy well your honor a big boy
yeah be fun though J's get involved
how many fun I'd do it with him dude
spoke into me so fun I can't [ __ ]
wait that's all I think get me through
the day I can't wait
how badly do you miss getting up on
stage bo yeah ah all right kids
see that's it and chin where are my
noodles oh yeah we could make them if
you wanna lose are down this is hot
chicken ramen oh yeah we can make in
then I'll bring it on Monday okay
so shut it that's it this is a fire kid
bonus episode we're out I love these
fires